cha la nasa s'intéresse aux astéroïdes
et les risques de collision qui pourrait
avoir lieu avec la terre l'agencé
américaine a pour projet d'identifier la
plupart de ces astéroïdes qui lorsqu'ils
ne dévie pas de leur trajectoire peuvent
menacer la planète
nicolas chateauneuf 40 go il s'appelle
2004 fh 29 films mesure près de cent
mètres de diamètre et est passé tout
près de la terre il ya seulement
quelques semaines
l'astéroïde a été découvert sur cette
image par une équipe australienne
financés par la nasa
la première dans l'hémisphère sud à
traquer les objets spatiaux présentant
une possible menace pour notre planète
et la moisson est bonne en un mois trois
astéroïde ont été repérés dans cette
région du ciel les dangereux ce sont
ceux qui font ils ont la centaine de
mètres parce que cela on n'a pas les
moyens de les voir avec les télescopes
et c'est solex peuvent provoquer à
l'échelle régionale les catastrophes
importantes qui ne mettront pas en péril
la civilisation où l'humanité mais qui
peuvent rasé une ville exemple en 1908
un astéroïde avait littéralement ravagé
une région de sibérie
mais attention pas de panique les
chances qu'une catastrophe survienne à
l'échelle planétaire sont faibles de
l'ordre d'une pour plusieurs millions
d'années
de plus dans le monde entier des équipes
d'astronomes se mobiliser le sigle
d'anciens télescope pour traquer
répertoriés et calculer la trajectoire
des objets dangereux environ un millier
un travail utile car le jour où l'on
découvrira une menace réelle
les scientifiques auront sans doute
besoin de plusieurs années pour mettre
au point une parade efficace